I have a first date trick that went
really well can I show you yeah sure
okay so I'll just pretend that you
pretend that I don't we're on a date
yeah tell we're on a date and I'm sure
I'll be go fall for him Conan I'll be
Conan inna code Anita take a card out
with some white space what's up okay
I'll say that right there
all right okay take the card and will
you sign your name on it coming yeah
sure okay now this trick is eBay this
trick is called up this trick is
actually this is like the sleight of
mouth trick okay so one is uh that's my
signature right perfect cool that's not
actually for the trick this is for my
mom I know we're gonna take that the the
eight of Hearts Conan card and I'm gonna
have you if you don't mind just hold
this in your in your mouth hold it yeah
I'm gonna fold it up and you just just
just bite onto it just with my teeth
with your teeth
okay fantastic yeah and I will sign a
card as well all right I will sign the
the nine of diamonds here okay that's
the Justin card okay and I will do the
same thing okay and then here we just
have to pretend we're on a date
the offensive touch touched it just
touch them I probably over Chuck KITT
yes this touch - okay that's a weekend
truck does this is like just every
eighth graders nightmare yeah just touch
the tip this was my eighth grade dream
right here so so Conan what happens is
check it out I actually now have the the
Conan Karl get in close that's crazy and
Conan now has the way that's crazy
look at that there's your Justin card
right there I felt nothing like that I
felt nothing cold so much that was
wonderful
you